انضم إلي الآن كوزير للخارجية
أنتوني بلينكين، السيد الوزير، شكرًا
لانضمامك إلينا، لذلك وقفت الولايات المتحدة بمفردها في
مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة يوم الجمعة لعرقلة
وقف إطلاق النار، والإدارة
تنحاز إلى تحرك الكونجرس لإرسال المزيد من
الأسلحة إلى إسرائيل، كما قلت هذا الأسبوع.
اقتبس فجوة بين نية
حماية المدنيين الفلسطينيين والنتائج
الفعلية التي نراها على
الأرض في غزة، هل يمكنك وصف هذه الفجوة، ما الذي
تفعله إسرائيل الآن والذي
تعتقد أنه لا يُظهر ما يكفي من الرعاية
أو الحماية للمدنيين الفلسطينيين؟
أعتقد أنه يجب أن
يكون هناك أولوية لحماية المدنيين
والتأكد من
وصول المساعدة الإنسانية إلى كل من يحتاج
إليها وكما قلت أعتقد أن النية
موجودة ولكن أه النتائج لا
تظهر نفسها دائمًا ونرى ذلك
على حد سواء  فيما يتعلق بحماية المدنيين
والمساعدة الإنسانية، نريد
التأكد من استمرار إسرائيل في هذه
الحملة لأنهم يتذكرون أنهم
يتعاملون مع منظمة إرهابية
شاركت في أبشع أعمال
وحشية ممكنة في
7 أكتوبر وأوضحت أنها
ستفعل ذلك.  مرارًا وتكرارًا إذا
أتيحت الفرصة لإسرائيل، فيجب أن
تكون قادرة على التعامل مع هذا لحماية
نفسها لمنع حدوث السابع من أكتوبر
مرة أخرى، ولكن بينما تفعل ذلك، فمن
الضروري حماية المدنيين
وهنا الشيء الحاسم هو
التأكد من أن  تم تصميم العمليات العسكرية
حول حماية المدنيين
والتركيز على ذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمساعدة الإنسانية، كما
تعلمون لقد طرحنا الحجة منذ عدة أسابيع
للحصول على المساعدات الإنسانية التي
بدأت تتدفق، لقد تضاعفت خلال فترة
التوقف الإنساني لـ  إطلاق سراح الرهائن
الذي ساعدنا في التفاوض عليه لكن
المهم الآن هو هذا حتى مع
اتخاذ إسرائيل خطوات إضافية على سبيل
المثال لتحديد مناطق آمنة في
الجنوب أه للتركيز على الأحياء وليس
المدن بأكملها من حيث إجلائهم
ما لا نراه  يكفي أن نتأكد من وجود
شيئين، الأول هو التأكد من
أن القائمين على العمليات الإنسانية
الموجودين هناك بدءًا من
الأمم المتحدة يقومون بأداء بطولي بحيث يكون هناك
أوقات اشتباك في الأماكن والجذور
حتى يتمكن العاملون في المجال الإنساني من تقديم
المساعدة التي تدخل غزة إلى
الأشخاص الذين يحتاجون إليها  وبالمثل نحتاج
إلى رؤية نفس النوع من عدم التضارب أه
الوقت أه التوقفات أه المعينة جذور جمع
وليس ليس واحد فقط أه وأه
ووضوح التواصل حتى
يعرف الناس متى يكون آمنًا وأين
يكون آمنًا للتحرك للخروج من الأذى
قبل أن يعودوا إلى ديارهم، هذه هي
الأشياء التي نعمل عليها كل
يوم مرة أخرى للتأكد من أن
الفجوة بين النية والنتيجة
ضيقة قدر الإمكان